acte avec christelle à une salle it
infirmières
bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france le 15 septembre
approche donc à grands pas que comptez
vous faire contre cette obligation
vaccinale est ce que vous espérez que
votre appel à la grève et des
conséquences
bien écouter oui parce que nous sommes
vraiment très très nombreuses à
s'opposer au bac 5 que nous soyons
en libéral ou au chu
cette obligation vaccinale pour nous n'a
aucun sens
quand lors de la première vague a en été
sur le front ont constaté les 17 et même
nous qui remplace on est médecin auprès
de certains patients
pour constater voilà pour faire des
soins et là maintenant devient les
vêtements parce que on refuse de se
faire vacciner donc voilà c'est juste
pour nous c'est quelque chose de
totalement aberrant
on sait que vous êtes 25 à 30% du
personnel à être entièrement vacciner ce
qu'il y en a beaucoup qui ont reçu
seulement une dose et qui pourront donc
être épargnées face aux conséquences de
leur désobéissance disons ça comme ça
mercredi alors chers queens park je
pense que 50% de ses 30% ont reçu une
première dose
mais seront pas épargnés pour autant
puisque tant qu'on n'aura pas eu la
deuxième dose voilà il a l'obligation
d'avoir de recevoir la deuxième dose au
1er octobre quand je crois et au 1er
octobre tout le monde tous ceux qui
n'ont pas eu le statut quo complète vont
se retrouver
dans l'obligation soit de ces fêtes de
son travail sans rémunération soit fait
démissionner
est ce que beaucoup de vos collègues ont
décidé justement d'aller se faire
vacciner puisque visiblement ils n'ont
pas le choix s'ils veulent pouvoir
continuer à travailler et toucher
toucher leur salaire
hélas et voilà on se retrouve contraint
de s'incliner contre évidemment contre
notre volonté beaucoup d'entre nous
bon le refuse de façon catégorique en
disant 20 alors il faut savoir que des
liens à l'hôpital on a une pénurie de
personnel on
ils sont déjà en sous-effectif
suis
70% puisqu'on est 30% être vaccinés si
70% des infirmiers et des soignants
arrêtent de travailler
l'hôpital tourne plus se terminer donc
il va falloir que
d'un côté ou de l'autre ça shake parce
que ils vont encore rien toi pourra plus
fonctionner à l'hôpital et justement
vous pensez que les autorités peuvent
céder sur cette obligation vaccinale
on espère on espère que notre mouvement
va les faire payer et que
moi et qui vont avoir un sursaut de
2 milliards ayant à thouars cet appel à
la grève vous avez prévu d'autres
manifestations peut-être pour faire
entendre vos protestations et dénoncer
cette obligation vaccinale à pointe à
pitre
écoutez pour l'instant
je ne sais pas où on en est bon il ya
beaucoup de réflexion beaucoup de
discussions qui se font et on se réunit
à fait souvent pour savoir justement
quelle va être la politique n'y ait ni
la cua but a donné face à voilà ça alors
la face à la direction et à la drh qui
ils nous obligent à recevoir ce aux
accents que
80% des guadeloupéens refuse sur ses
toiles sur cette obligation vaccinale
des soignants que pensez-vous en fait de
cette stratégie du gouvernement qui a
donc décidé de contraindre les soignants
pour les obliger à se faire vacciner ce
que pour vous c'était dès le départ une
mauvaise idée une mauvaise manière de
faire oui et non l'obligation en général
n'est pas une bonne prière essayer de
convaincre essayer de
la discussion le dialogue l'obligation
non sachant que
vacciner pas vaccinés on sait que ce
vaccin ne nous empêche pas d'attraper
qu'ovide moi j'ai une collègue qui était
vacciné qu'elle fait de zone et qui
attrapent écovie de trois fois donc dont
les deux variants donc c'est toute cette
voie là c'est tout ça qui fait que
pourquoi donc obligé alors que voilà la
protection en aura pas et la
transmission est toujours possible c'est
ce que la plupart des soignants de
comprennent pas et n'accepte pas merci
beaucoup
merci beaucoup qui c'est là où votre
témoignage je rappelle que vous êtes
infirmières en guadeloupe merci à vous